our single best chart on this friday
morning shows the increasing
significance of streaming to the music
industry this is from the recording
industry association of america
ad-supported and subscription streaming
services make up more than one-fifth 21
percent of the total music industry
revenue as of 2013. that is up from
seven percent in 2010 and three percent
in 2007 now globally
physical music sales still make up the
majority of revenue but that we know is
falling and even within digital music
revenue mp3 sales or something the big
winners of course are spotify pandora
and other streaming sites uh and
speaking of which it's been a
record-breaking week for singer taylor
swift do you remember what she did
she decided to drop her albums from
spotify and to celebrate she posted this
video on instagram and she has joined us
in studio taylor swift welcome to
surveillance well thank you so much i
love that ensemble scarlett you look
great so do you i'm the great fan of
it's a love fest because i love you too
uh listen you decided to make this bold
move by dropping your albums from
spotify as a protest against how little
they are paying artists like yourself i
don't know i gotta tell you i was born
in 1989 i was not born yesterday so
globally you know physical sales still
account for 51
of of of music stuff music revenue
domestically we're talking about 23
excuse me i'm sorry who's the guy over
there with a hell of a bad habit taylor
did you know your career was on it was
when did you know your career had made
it when you you and the boys from
sheffield england def leppard when you
came out on stage
who are you okay thank you